ladies gentlemen people with awesome
taste and you know that because you're
subscribed to me how are you sorry I
haven't done a video in a while I've
been moving and moved suck in there
terrible and no one really likes them
but it's happening and that's why I
haven't done a video for a few days but
now hey let's make some time for that
Jack the giant-killer or it's Jack the
giant slayer now because killers too
violent in a movie about giant city
people so Jack the giant slayer is the
story of Jack and the Beanstalk but you
know that really updated epic type of
style that people are doing nowadays
with fairy tales like Snow White and all
that yeah now it's the whole Jack and
the Beanstalk thing and I was on the
fence about this I was like Bryan Singer
he did this movie he's done good movies
he's done great movies he's done other
movies but if for nothing else I wanted
to see a really cool epic Jack in the
Beanstalk type movie with Ian McShane a
new McGregor go into Netley they're both
in here weird is that I didn't really
wish for that but if I could go back I
would have and in this movie there's a
bit of a twist on the fairy tale because
you know they want to update it but
there's a really cool way they go about
it long story short Jack who's this
peasant kid he gets these beans the bean
stock goes up to the cloud snatches up
the princess yeah it's super mario
brothers without pipes
now when Armada of guys go up there and
Jack's like I'll volunteer because she
is hot she's way hot too it's funny I
was watching this movie and I was like
I'm gonna talk about how she's hot and
some subscribers will be like I knew he
would she's out of control though I was
like you need to be in more stuff funny
thing though Jack the giant slayer is
actually entertaining that's pretty much
the BFG - the f there's just big giants
this movie is rated PG s made for kids
and family as you know as you go into
this movie code okay kid and family
moving in that this movie actually does
have some dark parts we're like whoa
that happened in a kid ish family issue
V but if you go into this movie scene
like oh yeah Giants are gonna eat people
it's gonna be badass and you watch
you're gonna be like it's almost like it
was a rated PG family movie which is
what it is the movies not without flaws
generally speaking everyone did a really
good job in the movie there are a couple
of things in the movie though where I
was like why is why is that just that's
it why is that fat Stanley Tucci's in
the movie he does a good job in the
movie I understand it's supposed to be
the dick but you know he's just the dick
then something happens where you're like
okay that's why you're in the movie
until then you're like why are you the
dick and why do you have salacious crumb
over here doing his thing this dude I
was like you're you're a cartoon the
Giants look like cartoons in that you're
like I wish the CGI for the Giants was a
little better in this movie but at least
they didn't act like cartoons this guy
acted like a cartoon yeah let's phantom
Edit him out if we can that is for the
Giants looking like CGI I do get why
they do and there was a part of the
movie where I was like it would be cool
if these Giants were played by people
for the most part they're not so
absurdly out of control to where you
couldn't have people in makeup look like
them couple of them would be stretches
but for the most part you
fine but if these things looked
realistic like they were people in
makeup and kids watched it they'd be
scarred they did that to us in the 80s
with legend I was never the same
so I getting them going years okay if it
was Jack the giant-killer
maybe we could have people in makeup but
it's the giant-slayer in the end I had a
good time with this movie it was a
really cool take on Jack in the
Beanstalk everyone did a good job except
for salacious crumb they're gonna have
fun you're gonna have adventure and
you're actually gonna have a really cool
throwdown at the end I was like yeah
this is like the kids Helms deep right
here any kid was ever like but mom I
want my helms deep they have it now they
can purge the fixation I will say Jack
the giant slayer or killer whatever you
want to call it is a good time no
alcohol required watch it love it and
tell your kids that shit's real so
they'll do what you say so this point I
feel like you have seen Jack the giant
slayer now so have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and we're back
on track now you will have videos
regularly sorry about the five day
hiatus I hope you enjoyed the reruns in
the meantime and as always if you like
what you seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more